hi guys you might not know but I am
currently in university studying
computer games arts I was originally
studying at digital film and screen arts
with a love for narrative and
storytelling however I transitioned over
last year and at the moment I'm pretty
busy on making my first term of this
year's game when I'm super stressed out
with uni whack and I just don't know
what to do with myself
you guys really helped to push me
through and I wanted to do something for
you one of you awesome awesome people
taco Flacco played my game last year
because I made a game last year my very
first one in the Uni course and it
wasn't the best but he played it anyway
and it is available for download so I
thought today while I'm stressed out
making my next game for this year I want
to just sit down and watch taco Flaco
play my last game yeah I want to see
what you guys thought of the game that I
made let's watch his video and I'm gonna
do react to I don't like these that much
for I think this is relevant because
it's my game and he's saying my game so
you know it's like a react to thinking
thing okay yes you get it but let's just
do just do the thing well that's much
the game was called coma and basically
it was a walkthrough game we weren't
allowed to put any textures on anything
since why it doesn't look that pretty
but we were 3d modeling it so I three
moudou modeled it and I coated it and I
created this game that type of Flacco is
now played so shoosh shoosh
I will shoosh and we will listen to the
game what happened last night
honey Q turn off the alarm it's getting
annoying honey honey that's not my alarm
in fact that's his voice like didn't add
a voice to know what did I get myself
into this time I forgot the groan groan
maybe I really do need to cut down on
the liquor is anybody there
could someone choking voice back play
getting scared you know my gosh who's
flickering off in our lights the lights
are flickering on and off who is that
who is seriously doing that oh my gosh
who is it Oh
Nosferatu oh the little tricky little
vampire yeah
gotta love that guy what is this wow
this place looks sweet
the sky is awesome it all this musics
jamming can you guys hear this its
royalty free music tuck around okay can
I get at people's houses
although music said I got your stuff I
mean I'm not not really I just want to
take your kid yeah they don't realize
he's a [ __ ] and I can't get any of the
houses I want to go in this house in
that house and what is what's that in
the air what is it that's Toby Bevin in
a little bamboo how is it flying in the
air is that it they modify in the
spaceship he's a smart cow Oh what snow
in here - what what's that noise lady
there's a lady I can well there's a lady
there's a lady this way but the music's
back this way I wonder where I can shoot
I'm gonna choose music yeah Jim it okay
fine fine fine
I wish you well
hey lady hello oh wait I was good hello
don't worry I'll get you out
I am here to save you miss lady down in
the well even though it's your fault for
falling in the well like seriously why
would you do that
hey she could've been put in the way how
do I save you hold it up taco
quit chill out is there anything this
way is what I'm stuck quit yelling I'm
trying to save you yeah yeah yeah it was
a bug way you get some if he walked on a
certain time you see anyway guess I'm a
nice person
okay this is an ex canvas your yelling
is really loud seriously chill out okay
I'm here to save you late late I gotta
open the door first hook it looks like a
little bird chop again I'm glad you
enjoyed the aegis code it's it's not
working um oh there it is
I just had to click on the outside I
thought you were supposed to hit the top
would like a little
a little bird should we go down oh look
I can see my hands in my body
thanks Kerry
I don't want to go down there there
could be snakes spiders or even worse
expired tacos okay if I don't go down
there I'm not a chicken a little bit I'm
a little bit chicken
hopefully gosh what's down here okay
nothing scary doesn't scare what's on
this one oh my gosh what is that it's so
scary look at that poster what poop oh
my gosh oh my gosh
yeah I just can't even today just poop
it's just dude okay
like lady alright are you okay I hear
screech where is she where lady I hear
are you with a really dark in this way
in the radio what is going I'm gonna
click it off wait lady it oh did I just
get trolled am I am I gonna get stuck
down here they gonna come I stalked out
here what is this
wake up what do you mean wake up it's
Karma oh my gosh hey hey somebody wake
me up please I'm scared but first I want
to plan a new song it's it's gonna be
very lovely I want to play this junk
oh yeah Jim that is more true to the
actual songs I use this game I can wake
up any time now I'm trying I'm trying
yes but I can't I don't know how at that
time stuck let us all sauna ending don't
worry lady I'm a nice person I'll come
and save you I'll go down the well just
kidding I have a grenade for you he'll
there he goes oh oh it blew up
I'm evil it didn't go better than
expected okay thank you guys so much for
watching
oh my god that was fun I'll see you guys
in the next video and yes sir this was a
really cool see you guys Cheers
Tucker that was super super fun to watch
someone play my game because I know it's
it's the thing is when you make a game
if you've only got a few weeks to do it
you can't do much with it especially
when you're doing all the 3d modeling
and everything else that comes along
with it but yeah someone enjoy the game
and do something different with it that
editing there's kids yo and check out
the video for yourself and also I will
leave links in the description to the
video on his channel and as well as that
the links to where you can download my
buggy buggy game and have some fun with
it yourself oh I would love to hear your
feedback because I think I'm working on
another game now and I'm gonna be
working on games further for awhile I
love film but I also love games and
making an interactive kind of
environment in a game world I feel like
I can do so much if I understand how to
make a game I can make a 360 video I can
make VFX and everything else so anyway
that's what I'm doing right now making
games and I'm gonna be sharing them with
you hopefully in my last year I actually
want to make a game with you and we can
chat about how that can work and I can
actually follow you through the
processes of me making my final 30 game
but anyway up until then I just wish you
a good day or even though a lovely daily
thing I forgot my ending have a lovely
day or evening bye